Hello, this is Dr. Kevin Connors and this presentation is on three things you could do right now
to help prevent cancer.
Cancer rate is the rise as you probably heard.
One in two American males, one in 2.5 females are going to get cancer
within their lifetime. That's staggering statistics. That's just absolutely crazy.
So if you're not getting a good cancer, look to the left of you and that person's gonna get cancer.
So it's just, that's just insane.
So there's got to be some things you could do to help prevent it.
It's, believe me, it's hard enough dealing with cancer when you have it.
If you could do things to prevent it, you're going to be much better off.
So here's some real practical things that can really help you.
Number one is change your diet.
So all diet and exercise can that solve everything?
Well, pretty much yes.
So changing your diet, the rule that I have for diet is eating things as close to the way
God created them.
So if you're grocery shopping, typically it's eating the perimeter,
meaning that you're going around, you're eating fresh fruits and vegetables,
fresh meats, fresh things refrigerated,
the perimeter of the grocery store.
But you want to try to eat organic because you could even be in the fresh fruits
and vegetable aisle and you're eating some GMO products that are very damaging to your
gut. So you want to try to eat organic and the old adage that I can't afford organic,
well, you have to cut some other things out to be able to afford organic,
which means eating less food.
That's another rule in this.
There's so many studies done on decreasing calorie consumption.
It can be the best thing for your health.
Now, you know, one of my degrees is an anti-aging and there's just so many studies
that prove that a reducing one's caloric intake is the number one thing you can do
to increase longevity.
So spend less money, stop buying Doritos and start buying organic fruit and vegetables.
That's a huge thing.
People have asked me, what would you do?
What would be the one thing you would do if you found out you had cancer?
Well, the one thing I would do if I found out I have cancer is it's something I should do now
before I have cancer is I would stop eating.
So it's hard because I'm kind of addicted to eating, but decreasing your calorie consumption
is the best thing that you can do.
Start buying organic, eat things the way God created them, buy less processed foods,
try to eat things fresh, grass fed meats, change your diet, make these changes for the better
and it will change not just cancer, rate, results, but it'll change other disease rate results.
It'll be the best thing that you did.
Number two, find it outlet for your stress.
You used to say, you got to get rid of your stress in your life and that's easier said than done.
Yes, it is true that you are really one or two major decisions from a completely changed life.
If your job is like killing you, what would it be like if you just quit?
What would it be like if you found something you love?
Now, I understand you're stuck in the golden handcuffs and you can't quit.
You can't get a job that pays you this much.
You have obligations to meet.
You're not willing to make the decision to sell the big house and to downsize.
You have four kids that you're trying to take care of.
How am I going to get rid of stress?
It's just not going to go away.
Well, that's why I put this number two in there.
Find it outlet for your stress.
OK, maybe the stress isn't going to go away, but how can I better deal with it?
Can I schedule time that I'm going to go outside and just walk in the woods?
Can I schedule time that I'm going to get away and just be by myself?
Can I schedule time that this is my book time?
This is my devotional time.
This is my Bible reading time and it's just something you write in stone and you're going to stick to that.
That's going to be your stress reduction kit instead of banging your head right here.
So find it outlet for your stress.
The third one is get some functional testing done.
And by functional testing, I do not mean going in and getting, you know, a complete physical with an MRI or a colonoscopy.
That's that we're talking about.
We're not talking about cancer screening tests.
We're talking about function tests.
So by function tests, I mean doing something like toxicity testing.
So this is an example of a doctor's data lab that we use.
And this is a urine provocation testing for heavy metals and other toxins that may be in your body.
Now, this is a standard test that we see at a lot of people.
They're high in multiple different heavy metals there that they need to deal with.
These are the things that cause end up causing chronic disease.
And that's what cancer is.
So, but even taking away cancer, chronic diabetes, heart disease, et cetera, et cetera.
All the things that we end up dying from in this country are much due to toxic exposure.
So getting some toxicity testing done and that appropriately dealing with that.
So if it's a heavy metal toxicity doing the chelation therapy
and other things to help heal your gut can prolong your life and strongly decrease your cancer risk.
Other testing would be micro testing.
This is a GI microbiology test where it's a stool sample test to see if you have parasites
and other different GI parasites that could tell if you have to do some intestinal cleansing
and parasitic cleansing that could be really beneficial for you.
Different kinesiology test he could find out if you have a chronic H. Pylora infection.
H. Pylora, he'll go back to Pylora, a grab negative bacteria, is at least in the top 10 causes of most cancers
that we find in the United States.
It's in the top three causes of heart disease of all people that dropped out of a heart attack
or end up having cardiovascular disease of some kind.
H. Pylora is at the top three causes of that and 99% of the time the person never knows they have it.
That's why it's called a chronic subclinical, you never knew you had this infection.
So chronic subclinical infections can be the cause of a lot of major diseases
and they are a major cause of cancers.
So get that, there's ways to get that tested and get that treated long before it becomes
you know, you end up dropping that of a heart attack or end up with a cancer diagnosis.
Really important and then do some genetic testing.
This is a sample of a DNA methylation pathway test with all these little things,
all these letters, this SHMT, this MTHFR, and MTRR,
all these different letters on the left hand side of this blood test are gene steps.
A gene step is a single nucleotide polymorphic,
these are gene defects that can take place in a person's body and if you have these gene defects
like in this example right here, all the ones in the grid are normal, the ones in the red are
abnormal, this person has a lot of gene defects.
Now typically people only get a genetic pathway test out if they have a chronic disorder,
like a chronic autoimmune disease or a chronic Lyme disease.
We do this on all our chronic Lyme disease patients and most of our cancer patients know
and we see pictures just like this, this is actually a patient of ours.
So these gene defects cause all sorts of problems depending on the gene itself.
It causes a decrease in their ability to detoxify, so again it goes back to,
if you have a decrease in your ability to detoxify, you're going to have an increase
of persistence of toxins in your bloodstream that are going to settle in your tissue and that
can cause all sorts of problems. So getting genetic testing can be extremely beneficial and then
properly treating based upon what you find on that genetic test and the other tests.
You can see some of my videos on genetic testing on our website if you want to too.
Other testing, other functional lab tests, there's a whole bunch of them and there's
a bunch that we do. I love lab tests, so we'd love to see these different tests. This is what I love
too. This is called the Organic Profile and it gives a whole bunch of different metabolic markers
that can point to different backups and different defects and different issues in metabolic pathways
in your body that can cause chronic fatigue, that could cause
methylation issues, that could cause problems with your mitochondria, your ability to detoxify
and oxidize and create energy and ability to live, and ability to make DNA and all sorts of problems.
So they can certainly interfere with apoptotic cycles and that is what cancer is. This is a cell
that can go through apoptosis and it is stuck in replication, so really important to know these kind
of things beforehand. So if you could do this different testing that know these things beforehand,
you could solve some problems because before they actually become symptomatic problems. There's
another test that we'd love to do. This is a hormonal test. So we'd like to look at a big hormonal
picture of people to see where there's defects and see where there's neurotransmitter markers
and see where where we need to correct some things and get to some core root of things.
All this testing we do in our office, we actually do this also for distance patients that we may never
see in our office and give them a report back on some real things that they could do
to make giant changes in their life as far as health go and really reduce their risk of cancer
and all sorts of chronic disease. So just call our office the numbers right there
or contact us. Make sure you visit our website. We have a bunch more videos on our website on all sorts
of things. So I hope this was beneficial and you can start preventing disease right now. All right,
thank you very much.